[Music]
thank you
g'day hey going so we're back again it's
Richard from off-road touring off now in
this video it's not so much a how-to
video it's more of a video of what you
need to turn your Jerry can into a
gravity fed system so when you are at
Camp you can actually leave your Jerry
can in the back of your car or if you've
got a wagon lock myself or in a canopy
I've got a list of bits and pieces you
need to actually turn that into that
system and I'll walk you through those
now and show you exactly what you need
to our setup it'll only cost you around
thirty dollars to do it so it is a
pretty cheap option rather than having
to Lug that out and the dog's waiting
for its ball to be thrown all right so
that should keep the dog happy for a
minute
now firstly we'll start from the end of
the Jerry can so obviously at the bottom
here you have a water Outlet there or
you can even fill it from it if you want
to once this is done I'll show you that
but you can take this off here a little
plug at the end so what you do need is a
20 mil BPA thread and it has a 13 mil
Barb on it so you'll find this in the uh
this is from the gardening section in
your local hardware store
so that just screws straight into there
so I've also got some uh Teflon tape now
I probably don't really need Teflon but
it doesn't hurt just to do a couple
wraps around it just to minimize the
chances of that leaking so what I'll do
now I'll um put the tape on it
and I'll take that little plug out hang
on a minute I'll get the ball in a sec
and then we'll uh show you the next step
now I know I said it's not really a
how-to video but that Phillips head
there that I have there is not really
adequate
and if I want to strip the uh
cap out so all I've done we're going to
use this shifter shortly but that
actually the back end of that fits an
egg not too bad
so I'll just unscrew that now
and then I'll uh Chuck a bit of tape on
here and I'll fit that in but this comes
in handy for when you want to tighten up
your thread into the Jerry can but
obviously you don't want to do it up too
tight because
it wouldn't take much just to strip out
that there but I'll put the tape on now
I won't film all that bit it's not that
exciting but uh I'll Chuck that in now
and get that bit set up
so earlier on I mentioned about this
thread here so your 20 mil BPA and I'll
talk you through the other
um parts that you'll need as well so
I've got myself a two meter uh garden
hose so it's already come with the brass
fittings and it's all crimped there nice
and tight So that obviously reduces the
chance of the hose leaking at all
and then I grabbed an inline tap now
that's got a uh from memory I think that
had the 13 mil thread on it as well now
the beauty of this is once it's all
connected I'll show you but that does
screw into the um the fitting on the end
there and that gives you your
tap and a hose clamp
and the tape
so just bottom screwing that in there
now
um You might be wondering why I didn't
get the food grade hose which in my old
camper trailer and stuff I definitely
use food grade but this jewelry can is
predominantly for
washing up or showering and things like
that it's we don't use it just for
drinking water we prefer to buy the uh
600 mL bottles and then we if for
waistbander away we actually squash the
bottles down screw the lid on so you
don't have big plastic bottles
everywhere but just for drinking water
we don't always use these of course if
we need an emergency we have got it but
that's why I've just used the garden
hose before any of you wonder why
I haven't used it it's because we
normally do it with the uh
oh with the water bottles that you buy
and they're relatively cheap now yep and
I'll just throw the ball to the dog
again I'll be right back
so I'll just nip that up
all right so I've got that all threaded
in there now I'll just hit the Jerry can
in the car where I'm going to actually
um
have it positioned and I'll cut this
hose to length make sure I cut it off
the right end of the hose of course
and then I'll uh
show you what the next step is or the
next part that I need which will be this
hose clamp here so I'm just going to
measure that up and I'll be right back
just got the old trusty layer them in
there
so that's about the length I'm going to
need I've just got the tap diamond in
there at the moment
and I'll uh give this a quick cut
[Music]
all right that should be the perfect
length there I'll grab that Jerry can
back here and I'll uh
connect the hose to it
all right so hang on
foreign
I've got but this is just one I had
sitting at home so basically I've just
cut the hose off there
I'm going to slide that on
like that
and
I'll get the screwdriver out the
Leatherman
tighten that up but before I do do that
I'll show you this hose fitting so
oh
hang on Scout
so got this fitting here
which comes with the uh which comes with
the hose obviously
it's already connected to it
so that's that's good and then I can
just screw that
tap on so nice and simple
just an inline tap there and the other
luxuries as well if you want to you can
even
get a connection get a connector and
leave it in your car or if it's mounted
permanently into canopy Etc you can
actually fill that up from the bottom up
but of course you want to be keeping an
eye on the top and not make sure that
you don't uh overfill it but
I'll uh go ahead and tidy uh tighten up
that hose clamp now and uh
do a test run
and see how it all goes make sure I've
got no leaks I've got that hose clamp on
the hose is on
and I'll just pop this uh
tap in now and then I'll fill it with
water and see how we go
so those of you with a Keen Eye will
notice that I've swapped Jerry can so I
swapped it out with the 18 liter Pro
quip for the 22 liter so the beauty of
this is quite simple to swap from Jerry
can to Jerry can depending on your trip
and how much room and all that sort of
stuff so it's quite a versatile little
uh setup so
as you can see it all works well I'll
probably leave water sit in it for a day
or two and I'll swirl it around and make
sure that I don't have any leaks but
it's just a matter of having the Gerry
can hire obviously turn it on
and then there's your water so no more
lugging this thing in and out of the car
when I'm away on weekends and
for a cheap thirty dollar mod it's nice
and easy 20 mil to 13 mil Barb with a
garden hose the hose clamp which most
people have probably got lying around
anyway and the inline tap which screws
neatly into the tap fitting so
oh nice and simple so and for those of
you wondering who is all that barking
carrying on in the background
this is her here our kelpie
so she's been in a couple of videos but
um yeah obviously loves their ball being
thrown
so we'll see you all next time cheers
[Music]
we were on our way